[Musique]
je suis un gastronome et pour beaucoup
cela se réduit à fréquenter les grands
restaurants à déguster foie gras poêlé
et autres pigeons farsi en sommes à être
très éloigné du commun des mortels et à
se limiter à une élite
c'est en partie vrai j'ai la chance de
fréquenter de belles maisons et de
rencontrer des gens passionnés mais pas
que mon travail me conduit à
m'intéresser aux pratiques en matière de
l'alimentation de l'homme j'ai une
appétence particulière pour les lieux où
manger et souvent tu un défi les
environnements de haute des tendances ou
le repas est cruciale les cantines
scolaires
le repas doit être un marqueur
d'éducation de goût et de sociabilité
les résidences pour personnes âgées
le repas doit être un marqueur de
bien-être et de plaisir et l'hôpital le
repas doit être un marqueur de nutrition
et dans vie je vais m'arrêter sur
l'hôpital savez vous que la dénutrition
est une des causes premières de
mortalité à l'hôpital quand on n'a plus
envie de manger on n'a plus envie de
vivre manger c'est se préoccuper de son
de son bien-être
je parle ici de manger non pas être
nourris ont peut être nourri à coups de
pilules ou ou de perfusion manger à
l'hôpital est considéré comme un soin
c'est un moyen de lutter contre la
maladie en mars 2
6 je mets une blouse blanche et pour
répondre à la demande du docteur cécile
chambrier qui dirige un service dans un
hôpital lyonnais et dans ce service les
malades qui à l'accueil sont tellement
dénutri qu'elle a du mal à les soigner
bien sûr beaucoup a déjà été fait mais
les résultats ne sont pas satisfaisants
et 70% du plateau repas par souvent à la
poubelle alors elle s'est dit que
l'institut paul bocuse pourrait l'aider
je passe une matinée à observer le
travail des aides soignantes
je dis c'est que leur organisation jeu
j'ai besoin de comprendre comment le le
repas est servi
ce qui me frappe c'est la rapidité la
discrétion avec laquelle le repas y
apporter aux malades dans la chambre le
plateau je vous apporte le plateau le
plateau est déposé sur la table qui
s'appelle adaptable très souvent presque
toujours encombrée de revues de journaux
d'ordinateurs et régulièrement et
régulièrement d'urinoirs donc tout ce
qui touche à l'environnement du repas
n'est pas mise en oeuvre j'ai une
intuition je pense que ce manque d'
actes liés à l'environnement du repas
peut être une des causes de la
difficulté de cette prise alimentaire
je convaincs l'hôpital de me confier les
aides soignantes et je les invite à
l'institut paul bocuse
elles sont impressionnés par le lieu et
elle sont étonnés par le fait que je ne
remettent absolument pas en cause
leur métier elles le font avec beaucoup
d'efficacité
en fait mon but est de leur faire
comprendre que la grande humanité
qu'elle déploie dans le nettoyage de la
chambre dans la propreté du lit dans la
toilette du corps cette grande humanité
est absente ou insuffisante
lorsqu'il s'agit d'apporter le repas aux
malades
parmi les exercices je leur fait dresser
le plateau comme elles le font sont
ordinairement et avec les mêmes éléments
je demande aux experts de l'art de la
table de l'institut de dresser le
plateau elle découvre alors avec
étonnement que ce plateau peut être
sublime et qu'il a une autre allure
qu'il est beaucoup plus attrayant elles
comprennent que servir à manger n'est
pas un protocole comme un autre elles
prennent conscience de l'importance de
la symbolique c'est à dire de ces petits
gestes de ces paroles de ce regard qui
paraissent anodins mais quand une grande
importance de retour dans leur service
elle met en oeuvre un plan d'action
le pliage de la serviette qui va être en
harmonie avec la période de noël
elle dessine elle confectionne des 7
pour les plateaux repas
en fait leur humanité libéré lorsqu'il
s'agit du repas cette expérience inspire
le professeur pierre singer qui dirige
un service de nutrition dans la zone
hôpital à tel-aviv
il fait une expérience sur 300 repas
servis sur une période de 28 jours la
prise alimentaire augmente de 30%
l'expérience étaient non concluantes
alors et vous maintenant comment
avez-vous déjeuner vous êtes vous à 6
avez-vous déjeuner devant votre
ordinateur
avez vous mis un set
une nappe pour le repas que vous avez
partagé avec avec vos enfants
ce matin avez-vous pris votre petit
déjeuner quand on se lève
normalement on petit des jeunes c'est à
dire que l'on casse le jeune
personnellement chaque soir je dresse la
table je prends le bol assiettes les
couverts avec lesquels j'ai l'habitude
de prendre ce ce repas jeux le complète
le matin en étant attentif aux gestes
qui sont les miens et je prends quelques
secondes pour regarder cette mise en
scène
chaque objet familier à un impact est en
fait ils deviennent une présence qui
développe une énergie dont je vais me
servir au cours de la journée je suis en
plein accord avec l'historien pascal ory
qui dit que la gastronomie n'est ni la
haute cuisine ni la bonne chère c'est la
mise en règle nomos du manger et du
boire transformé de ce fait en arts de
la table être gastronomes c'est être
capable de se créer
quel que soit le contexte le lieu un
moment où il se passe quelque chose
d'étonnant être capable d'être
absolument présent et ne souhaitait être
nulle part ailleurs que devant son repas
que l'on soit au bureau
sous les cocotiers ou à l'hôpital c'est
cette capacité à mettre tous ses sens en
éveil pour profiter de l'instant
en fait c'est le désir le désir d'avoir
de la joie le désir de d'un moment qui
est ressenti comme un cadeau un cadeau
que je me fais un cadeau que je fais à
l'autre en novembre 2010 le repas
gastronomique des français est inscrit
au patrimoine culturel immatériel de
l'unesco
mais quand faisons nous je suis de ceux
qui pensent que ce patrimoine cette
tradition est une réponse à cette
recherche de bonheur dans le quotidien
de nos vies il ne faut pas avoir peur de
la tradition la tradition elle nous
donne du lest elle nous libère à travers
le rituel elle nous oblige à être
attentif aux détails aux petites choses
le rituel finalement installe un rythme
une impression de lenteur de de déjà vu
mais qui donne de l'épaisseur autant
mettre une app à cette dresser une table
un plateau choisir un verre pour boire à
20 ce sont des détails mais qui
subliment l'instant du repas l'acte de
manger ne doit pas être mécanique encore
moins une mode c'est une manière de
vivre qui devient un art un art de vivre
le docteur jean trémolières mort il ya
40 ans est un des fondateurs de l'école
nutritionnelle française
il a compris que l'alimentation
contribuent à façonner l'homme non pas
sur un plan strictement physique
mais globale alors face aux pressions
qui sont les nôtres dont le monde
moderne où l'on parle sans cesse
d'efficacité de productivité de
rentabilité et donc ce bric à brac
intérieur avec lequel nous devons
composer
il nous reste à pouvoir de réenchanter
le quotidien de notre vie réenchanter le
quotidien de notre vie en ré en chantant
notre manière de manger penser aux
petits détails ne signifie pas penser
petit lorsque l'on mange
il contribue à faire briller à chaque
repas des étoiles dans nos yeux alors ce
soir j'ai un souhait c'est que tu es
d'exclusion dans le cadre de cette
rencontre soit une étincelle une
étincelle qui allume un feu de joie la
joie de la gastronomie
[Applaudissements]